Her low freak bitches watch is such a scary thing though because compromising
the ability to think correctly to me is one of the scariest things that could
happen to you.
That was,
I had Lyme disease and one of the,
and I spent three years in bed,
but the worst part about life,
I was really sick.
That's where the flow research came from.
Yeah.
I pulled myself out of it through surfing in these crazy altered states that I
was having while I was surfing.
And my first question was,
what the fuck has got right?
Surfing is not,
I've known Carol for chronic autoimmune conditions and why was having these
crazy altered state of consciousness experiences while surfing?
That's where it started for me.
Um,
but with Lyme I law,
I mean I,
you go crazy.
You become extremely paranoid.
The most common misdiagnosis for Lyme is paranoid schizophrenia.
So you become extremely paranoid.
I was hallucinating short term memory gone longterm memory,
gone beam dyslexic.
I couldn't write,
I couldn't even read cause I would get to the end of a sentence.
I couldn't remember the beginning of the sentence that I read.
But it's like watching yourself go mad.
I don't know of any,
I don't,
but I've been through a lot of physical pain.
I've been through a lot of different illnesses and whatever.
Nothing is worse than watching yourself go crazy.
Wow are fine.
But my good friend Tommy,
his girlfriend just this past weekend was telling me about she had Lyme and she
was misdiagnosed.
She had to go to just more than a,
I think she said more than a dozen different doctors before somebody finally
listened to her.
If you find it out,
my second book,
west of Jesus,
which is the book I write about this,
this is very early.
It's the first couple of pages on,
I have a list of all the diseases that I was told I had before.
They actually discovered his lime and it's,
you know,
it's a half a page of diseases.
It's just,
I'm so confused by that because Lyme is common.
So as well,
I,
first of all I was,
I had it,
I got it on the east coast,
but I was here.
I was living in California,
I was living in La at the time where they hadn't really,
now they've seen it,
but at that time nobody had really seen it and they didn't believe it was a west
coast disease.
And you know,
it's still this point that diagnostics are not fantastic for Lyme.
But what I was saying,
my friend Katie,
my friend,
Tommy's girlfriend Katie,
she lives in New Jersey or Connecticut rather,
where it's really common.
I mean like Connecticut is where it came from.
So they live in a place where it's really common in,
the doctor was like,
Matt,
not lying.
She's like,
I think it might be like,
nope,
not what I'm,
you're going crazy.
I went in,
I don't know if I could talk about this,
I can't talk about this a little bit,
but so that we'll keep names out of it.
So the first time I walked in to see my doctor,
um,
I've been sick for a while and I just moved to La so I didn't have,
or a regular practitioner.
I finally got one and I've been sick for a while.
So a lot of my friends had been trying to figure out what the hell was going on
me.
And one of my editors said,
Hey,
I've been doing research.
I think,
I think we have Lyme.
Go ask your doctor.
And I remember walking into the doctor's the first time I'd seen him and I was
like,
hey man,
I,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
This is what's going on.
Uh,
I think I have Lyme.
And he's like,
no,
you don't have Lyme,
you have aids.
Which by the way,
like,
you know,
I was like,
are you sure cause decided you were gay?
No,
I looked at him,
I was like,
are you sure be so my mother was one of the very first AIDS activists in Ohio.
So like I've been having protected sex my whole life or baby.
Yeah,
true.
That heterosexual,
no intervenous drug use.
And he said that time and you know,
almost any dudes,
nothing,
nothing.
At that point,
you know,
I'm willing to learn if you'll send me someplace special.
But,
uh,
so this guy to sign,
this guy just looks at me and the word gay.
No,
I thought I was like,
I was like,
buddy,
I'm not like I haven't add homosexual sex.
I've never used Ivy.
That was what happened.
And the worst thing is like,
you know,
go home to your girlfriend who you're living with and she's like,
how was the doctor honey?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Did he test you before?
He said No.
He tested.
That's just say I won the lawsuit.
Oh,
I know.
By the time it was all said and done,
Holy Shit,
you had a Su.
Wow.
It got really obnoxious.
I mean like they wouldn't test me for anything.
It,
it dragged on and on and on
because they,
they're worried that if they do test you for something and they confirmed that
they were incorrect and it sets them up for malpractice so they're trying to
drag it out.
It was an Hmo.
Thanks.
Insurance has changed.
But back in the,
this was early 2000 [inaudible] 99 98 I paid,
I think my premium loose HML cupboard was like,
let's say at the time it was like a couple hundred bucks a month of that 200
bucks a month,
$7 went to the doctor for testing.
The rest of went to the insurance company.
The doctor got $7 a month to treat me.
So how incentivized our that are run a bunch of big expensive tests.
So he looks at anybody on an Hmo is like aids.
You got a these days,
get them to run out of my office.
Hopefully the guy will just do drugs and die.
Just drink himself to death.
It was ugly.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So this was a long time ago when lime wasn't nearly as prevalent.
Now Lyme is a God damn scary disease because I don't know when it originated and
they just started sort of treating people for it over the last few decades.
Right.
I don't,
um,
I don't know if this is still true,
but there was a period of time where it was the first of the second biggest
communicable disease viral disease in the world.
He was second
eight.
Well,
one of the things I studied,
um,
I did this show called a Joe Rogan questions,
everything for Psi Phi.
And one of the things that we looked into with something called more challenge,
do you know what more challenges?
More Jaylen's is a very controversial disease where people feel like they have
fibers growing out of their skin and they scratch themselves and develop these
like open sores from itching.
And then they think that like they'll get like carpet fibers in their skin,
they'll think it's coming out of their body,
like we'll have like fibers from their clothes that they'll detect on their
skin.
And so it has sort of weird psychological aspect to it.
What's interesting about it is a disproportionate number of people who have more
challenge or believe they haven't test positive for Lyme disease.
So I was talking to a doctor who had more jealous,
who also has Lyme and he was very candid and honest about it.
He,
he thinks that there's a direct risk.
There's something going on.
There was a neurotoxic effect that's happening with the Lyme disease that's
twisting his mind.
Does,
I mean crazy?
I'll tell you.
I was at,
that's why I wanted to talk to you that Fairfax and sunset.
I was driving my car,
it was just stick and it was,
I was coming back from the doctors.
This was a typical Lyme,
what happens to your brain and um,
the light's red and it's rush hour.
You know what Fairfax and sunset is like at rush hour and uh,
the light turned from red to green and I no longer know what green means.
Look,
my brain is just like,
and I'm like,
what am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do?
People are flocking and hawking.
And finally I'm like,
Oh crap.
Green means go.
And I looked down at the stick shift and I no longer have not remember how to
drive stick.
I had to literally get out and people had to push my car and to whatever that
little grocery store is right there to the party.
So like,
you know,
fundamental skills that I'd had since I was 16 years old.
And you know,
the ability to go when the light turns green.
I mean you watch yourself go crazy.
Wow,
that must be insane.
But you knew how to walk.
You knew how to talk.
You need her to say there's something wrong.
You had full access to the language that had full access to land.
I couldn't write.
I started developing a select like scrabble words up when I was writing,
but I could talk.
I don't think I ever lost my powers of speech that I remember.
What a scary little fucking disease.
Lyme is,
was weird,
scary,
creepy disease.
Well,
this doctor,
he was absolutely convinced that the two of them were correlated.
He said that there's something going on with Lyme disease that produces this
thing where you,
you start seeing these fibers coming out of your body and uh,
you know,
we,
we had a ton of people like to send in videos and show us images and they had
slides that they had prepared.
They were convinced these fibers were coming out of their skin.
And so doctors oftentimes just completely label it as a psychosomatic disorder.
But this one doctor who had it said,
I believe that the correlation is Lyme disease and it completely makes sense.
Listen to what you're saying.
The other thing is everything is a psychosomatic disease,
right?
I mean,
there's not an aids.
Well,
the mine,
all I was saying is that,
I don't mean it that way.
It's kind of funny now because it's a,
it's like you could kind of avoid,
it used to be,
we were all worried everybody's going to die.
Like you can joke around about aids now,
which is rare.
You know,
if you look at like the,
the time when Magic Johnson came out as HIV positive,
everybody was terrified.
We're all going to die.
You know,
I lost a lot of friends during that period.
I'm sure you,
cause they thought you had aids.
No.
Okay.
So
I might've lost
some friends that way too.
But uh,
yeah.
But for you,
what did they have to do to you to get you off the alarm disease and his,
isn't lime something you keep semi-permanently so I mean,
I,
you know,
I was in bed for three.
I mean I'll tell you the year.
Yeah,
it was in bed for about three years.
They had to pull me off antibiotics cause my stomach lining started bleeding
out.
Um,
there was nothing else maybe we could do for me and up just tell you the full
story and I was going to end my life.
I like,
I was at that point I was functional but 10% of the time,
maybe like an hour a day,
I couldn't work.
The only thing I was going to be was a burden to my friends and my family.
And I was just like,
alright,
at the time,
30,
um,
and uh,
in the middle of this I was,
it was what,
I was still living in Los Angeles.
A friend of mine showed up at my door and said,
we're going surfing.
I secured to your fucking mind.
I can't walk across the room.
I mean,
I literally couldn't do it and she wouldn't shut up and wouldn't leave and
wouldn't leave and wouldn't,
he's trying and after like it just hard to make a point of she's going to drown
me four hours of this or three hours a day.
I was like,
fuck it,
let's go surfing today.
I mean,
what's the worst that can happen?
Right.
I'll always kill myself tomorrow and a drag me out to sunset beach.
And they literally sort of had to walk me to the car.
I take it,
you know,
by the shoulders.
Cause I was,
it was really,
we,
you know,
they gave me a fourth the size of a Cadillac in the bigger the board,
the easier it is to surf.
And this was enormous and it was a tiny day.
Like waves were like two feet at best and was so crappy.
Nobody was even out,
but the water was warm and they sort of like,
they took me by the elbow and they walked me out to the break and I was out
there and I knew how to surf a little bit.
It had been a longtime side surfed at that point,
but 30 seconds later or wave came and you know,
I don't know what happened.
Muscle memory took over whatever would,
I spun my board,
I paddled a couple times and I popped up and I just popped up from a dimension I
didn't even know existed.
Right.
So when the eye panoramic vision,
I felt like I could see out of the back of my head and I felt amazing.
I felt like that kind of full thrum of lifetime and slow down.
None of it made any sense.
It felt so good.
I caught like four more waves that day.
And by the fifth wave I was just,
I was disassembled.
They kinda put me back in the car and drove me home.
And,
uh,
I was so sick after that that I was,
I got into bed and people had to bring me food for like two weeks because I
couldn't walk to my kitchen,
which was like 60 feet away and just exhausted.
I was not surfing experience like the 15th Day,
which is the day I could walk again,
caught another ride back to the beach.
And I did it again.
Right.
And again,
I had this crazy altered state of consciousness experience.
And you know,
again,
I was disassembled this time,
maybe it was like 13 days that I was in bed and I did it again.
And over the course of about six to eight months where the only thing I was
doing differently in my life was surfing.
I went from about 10% functionality to about 80% functionality.
So my first question is the fuck is going on,
right?
Like as I said earlier,
surfing is not a known cure for chronic autoimmune conditions.
Right.
So,
and I lit out on a giant class.
The other thing was I backgrounds as a science writer.
So like I don't have quasi mystical experiences and I sure as hell don't have
them while surfing,
which has gotta be the flakiness,
you know,
thing ever.
Yeah.
And,
um,
so I really believed that even though I was feeling better lives,
only fatal if it gets into your brain.
And I was,
I was pretty sure that even though I was starting to feel physically better that
the disease had crept into my brain because why else would I be having these
mystical experiences?
I must be totally losing my mind.
I'm about to die.
And I lit out on a giant quest beer at what the hell happened.
And you know,
very quickly discovered that these states of consciousness have names.
We call them flow states.
And the version of what happened to me health wise,
um,
and this is her Benson did some of the work on the neurobiology of this.
He's at Harvard.
Um,
he wrote about it in his book,
the breakup principle.
But,
uh,
all the neurochemicals that show up and float,
two things happen.
So one,
when you move into flow,
there's a global release of nitric oxide.
It's a gas as signaling molecules anywhere in the body.
What it does is it flushes all the stress hormones out of your system and it
pumps you full of these kind of feel good performance.
Standard Lyme is an essentially any autoimmune conditions,
your nervous system gone haywire.
So when you go into flow,
it resets your nervous system,
calms everything down.
It gets rid of all the stress hormone and all that stuff and it,
and when,
the worst part about Lyme is you don't even know where normal is.
Like it has been so long since you have felt normal,
like you don't even,
you can't even find it on a map.
So suddenly like I was like,
oh,
this is what normal feels like.
Again,
the other thing is,
you know,
the positive neurochemicals that show up and float dopamine,
Serotonin and Nanda Amaanah see Towson.
Those are all immune system boosters.
I mean,
they do a ton of other stuff,
enhance cognitive performance and whatever,
but her Benson at Harvard,
and I think this may be overstretching,
uh,
a budget,
but he has kind of gone on record and said,
he thinks most cases of so called spontaneous healing actually have a flow state
at their heart.
And it's this particular process that's doing it.
Okay.